alors c'est la star c'est une c'est une
région habité par aujourd'hui 120000
Arméniens il y en avait 150000 avant
2020 mais 30000 ont fui les combats et
la guerre du de 44 jours qui a eu à
l'automne 2020 ou l'Azerbaïdjan a
attaqué cette région qu'elle revendique
comme la sienne en vertu du droit
international lui-même hérité du droit
que Staline a décrété en 1921 qui était
de rattacher cette région arménienne
depuis 3000 ans à la République
socialiste soviétique d'Azerbaïdjan et
en 2020 l'Azerbaïdjan a essayé de
reconquérir l'intégralité de cette de
cette région elle n'y est pas parvenue
grâce aux Russes qui sont intervenus
pour arrêter ce conflit et aujourd'hui
il reste un petit territoire grand comme
un petit département comme le Rhône
peuplé de 120000 Arméniens et puis il y
a quelques semaines
de la Grande Arménie du moyen-âge et le
12 décembre dernier les azéries le
gouvernement Algérie a envoyé des faux
militants écologistes qui n'ont jamais
indiqué quoi que ce soit en 40 ans de
pouvoir par la famille allieve pour dire
il y a des mines d'or qui polluent la
région donc on va chasser les ouvriers
le millier de d'ouvriers Arméniens qui
se trouve là et puis récupérer ton café
cette région les ouvriers les en ont
empêché du coup ils ont bloqué ce qu'on
appelle le corridor de la Chine qui
relie l'Arménie et la star dépendant à
90 % de l'Arménie pour tous ses besoins
donc depuis 50-43 jours pardon 44 jours
exactement il y a plus rien qui passe
entre l'armée l'airsart il y a plus de
médicaments il y a plus de vivre il y a
plus de gaz non plus parce que le gaz
passe par des tuyaux depuis l'Arménie
que les azéries coupent régulièrement
donc il y a plus de chauffage il y a
plus d'essence il y a plus de billets de
banque et la population est en train de
mourir de froid et de faim il y a à peu
près 30 000 enfants et 20000 personnes
âgées parmi ces 120000 personnes et le
monde semble un petit peu indifférent
cette situation très préoccupé par la
situation en Ukraine notamment et les
Arméniens appellent au secours les
instances internationales y compris
humanitaires y compris des droits de
l'homme les enfants par exemple n'ont
plus école parce que les le chauffer que
font les organismes internationaux qui
s'occupent du droit à l'inéducation par
exemple c'est ce que disent les
Arméniens aujourd'hui on va revenir sur
les conditions de vie des Arméniens mais
je le disais vous avez été reçu par
Emmanuel Macron lundi à ce sujet vous
n'étiez pas le seul pourquoi avez-vous
tenu à rencontrer le chef de l'État sur
ce sur ce sujet alors c'est vrai qu'au
figure magazine ça fait maintenant plus
de 2 ans qu'avec Sylvain Tesson on
essaie de porter la parole des Arméniens
lorsqu'on a couvert la guerre en arsée
on est revenu en disant attention ça
n'est pas fini ce n'est qu'un début
parce que les velléités des Turcs et des
Algérie elle est très simple elles sont
très simples c'est éradiquer les
Arméniens c'est chasser les Arméniens
comme des chiens de cette région donc il
ne s'arrêteront pas là demain ça sera le
reste de Larsa ou demain ce sera le sud
de l'Arménie de ce qu'on appelle le
sionique le zanguezo pour les pour les
azéri ça veut dire que les Arméniens
sont purement et simplement menacés
absolument dépuration ethniques c'est un
mot c'est un mot très fort c'est un mot
très qui a une connotation vraiment mais
quand vous regardez les discours de alyf
ou des Hermione c'est ça les Arméniens
sont une tâche qu'il faut effacer de
cette région donc on porte cette voie
avec Sylvain Tesson on a eu quelques
relais médiatiques ou politiques et un
certain nombre de députés de sénateurs
européens aux Français qui se sont
engagés mais un petit peu des voix
isolées et à un moment donné on s'est
dit on va essayer de d'aller voir la
personne qui seul politiquement peut
faire quelque chose qui est le président
de la République française donc avec
Pascal Bruckner Olivier Weber grand
reporter et qui a été ambassadeur des
droits de l'homme itinérant et Sylvain
Tesson accompagné du riz jorkaeff qui
qui est que le Président de la
République aime beaucoup et qui fait un
petit peu le relais aussi avec la
diaspora voilà on est allé voir Emmanuel
Macron lundi à l'Elysée en tout cas il a
accepté de nous recevoir pour parler
pendant une bonne heure de cette
situation ça a été compliqué d'obtenir
cette cette rencontre avec le chef de
l'État très franchement pas tant que ça
c'est à partir du moment où on a lancé
le processus
sur le principe pour vous dire la vérité
dans le figure magazine Sylvain et son
interpellés le président de la
République il y a quelques mois le
président de la République a répondu à
cet interpellation dans une émission
télé de
et ensuite le président de la République
est resté en contact avec Sylvain Tesson
en disant on se revoit pour parler de
l'Arménie et Sylvain l'a pris au mot en
disant voilà on est on est quelques-uns
on a fait une pétition mi-décembre dans
le Figaro de 300 intellectuels écrivain
artiste philosophe pour demander de de
d'agir pour sauver les Arméniens
d'assard c'était au tout début du
blocage et là on s'est dit ben les
pétitions c'est très bien les discours
c'est très bien les reportages c'est
très bien les tribunes c'est très bien
mais à un moment donné il faut passer
l'action politique le seul qui peut
passer à l'action politique et qui a
montré il nous a-t-il semblé l'envie de
le faire ces derniers mois on pour en
parler c'est Emmanuel Macron et donc on
a sollicité une rencontre et ça s'est
été décidé assez rapidement combien de
temps a duré cette rencontre et
qu'est-ce que une heure et qu'est-ce que
vous lui avez dit est-ce que vous l'avez
senti est-ce qu'il avait sorti concerné
est-ce que vous pensez avoir été entendu
alors oui alors concerné il y a aucun
doute il connaît par cœur la situation
mais vraiment il s'en note et pas le
l'hypermnésie où je récit des aimants de
langage il était vraiment d'une sécurité
totale il connaissait les noms des
villes les noms des les chiffres clés on
n'a pas besoin de rappeler des choses on
est vraiment très très vite aller dans
le dur du sujet nous nous c'est très
simple on lui demande que la France
prenne que lui Emmanuel Macron
présidente de la France qui est le seul
pays à avoir un moment donné condamné
formellement par la voix à l'if dans sa
stratégie d'avoir dit qu'il y avait des
mercenaires djihadistes qui étaient
utilisés par l'Azerbaïdjan et d'avoir
imposé une mission d'observation eu de
l'Union européenne à la frontière en
Arménie parce qu'encore une fois le
dangereux ce n'est pas que l'artère
c'est l'Arménie elle-même c'est ce sont
tous les Arméniens qui sont en danger
Macron porte ses voies tout seul en
Europe pour des raisons notamment liées
à la cheminement du gaz azeri en
remplacement si on peut dire du gaz
russe beaucoup de pays européens nous on
a besoin du gaz adhérer pour chauffer
puisqu'on puisqu'on on empêche on ne
veut plus du gaz russe donc on touche
pas à ça les Turcs ils ont les Allemands
beaucoup de Turcs dans leur territoire
et il y a que Macron qui qui fait des
choses des petites choses mais qui en
fait quand même donc c'est assez logique
de donc nous on lui dit faites-en plus
on lui dit aujourd'hui il y a une une
impasse politique puisque les Russes ne
font rien pour déloger ces asyries qui
illégalement occupent ce corridor faites
au moins ce que la France est très bien
faire c'est de l'humanitaire immédiat
mais l'humanitaire est toujours une
dimension politique c'est à vous envoyer
une mission humanitaire française de
massive pour débloquer ce corridor c'est
un geste politique parce que ça veut
dire que la France est derrière
l'Arménie et quand quand lazerbaïdjan
voit que la France est derrière
l'Arménie c'est pas que l'Arménie
c'est-à-dire en attaquant l'Arménie elle
attaque d'une certaine manière la France
et ça qu'on lui dit fête ce geste là
peut-être aller là-bas il y a plein de
choses qui peuvent être faites et qu'on
lui a proposé
il a dit non à rien qu'est-ce qu'il vous
a répondu ils ne disent non à rien
sur le la seule chose où il y a une
certitude c'est oui j'organise très
rapidement une une grande conférence
enfin plus confiance une convention je
sais pas comment appeler ça
international à Paris avec les
organisations humanitaires pour lancer
ce ce pont humanitaire qui irait au
moins jusqu'en Arménie avec objectif de
d'aller puisque les Russes laissent
passer quand même les camions de la
Croix-Rouge pour les cas gravissimes il
y a une trentaine de patients de
l'hôpital de ces panacab qu'on puisse
être rapatrier laissez passer des vivres
etc donc on fait ce pari d'envoyer que
le Président de la République la
République française prenne la tête d'un
convoi du Samuel qu'on voit humanitaire
à l'entrée du corridor de la Chine avec
des dizaines et dizaines de tonnes de
nourriture de vêtements de ce dont la
population a besoin et on essaye de
passer le corridor mais déjà ça il a
acté ça il nous a dit d'accord c'est
d'accord on organise ça à Paris très
vite c'est déjà une nouvelle c'est déjà
pas ça veut dire c'est déjà un geste
politique c'est pour ça qu'on veut dire
il a fait déjà une partie du chemin et
c'est un geste qui a vocation d'en
appeler d'autres est-ce que vous avez
par exemple proposé suggérer au chef de
l'État de se rendre en Arménie pour nous
c'est encore une fois c'est un geste
encore plus politique parce que si le
président de la République française
vient en Arménie à ce moment-là c'était
dans les semaines qui viennent et si le
blocus dur ça veut dire que il est
derrière
on veut croire que ne pas dire non ça
veut dire peut-être oui dans quelles
conditions à quel moment avec qui avec
l'intérêt même si ce représente pas il a
il a intérêt non mais il a vraiment un
intérêt la France a toujours été proche
de l'Arménie et intervenu lors du
génocide notamment 1915 sur le mont
Moïse pour sauver des milliers
d'Arméniens il y a un moyen de comme le
dit Sylvain Tesson de d'entrer dans
l'histoire de rester dans l'histoire par
un geste et puis pardon c'est le panache
c'est lorsque De Gaulle va dire vivre le
québec-lib à la barbe des anglophones au
Québec c'est la France lorsque
Mitterrand même si c'est pas forcément
utile arrive à Sarajevo en 92 en
première personne c'est la France donc
soyez la France Monsieur le Président
c'est ce qu'on c'est ce qu'on lui a dit
est-ce que vous lui avez dit on va
passer ensemble trois photos
Jean-Christophe pour présenter cette
actualité de l'Arménie et puis plus
précisément pardon de l'arc ça je vais
vous demander de les commenter la
première provient de votre compte
Twitter Jean-Christophe vous avez publié
cette photo ce matin et on voit une
scène de vie quotidienne d'une famille
arménienne en AXA oui je reçois beaucoup
de de photos d'artsar que j'essaie de
diffuser leurs parents en masse parce
que c'est mais celle-là m'a paru
particulièrement symbolique de la
situation comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure là au moment où on se parle il
fait moins 3 degrés à stepana 4 qui est
la capitale on est entre 1000 et 1500
mètres d'altitude et aujourd'hui il y a
des coupures d'électricité ou de gaz
donc de chauffage alors c'est pas toute
la journée parfois les coupures
d'électricité ils proviennent des
Arméniens qui font des économies mais le
gaz qui arrive et qui permet de chauffer
et les voitures aussi les voitures
roulent beaucoup gazogènes en Arsène en
Arménie et bien on se trouve dans des
situations comme ça ou des familles se
retrouvent autour d'un poil à bois pour
se chauffer ils n'ont plus que ça c'est
même les voisins qui viennent se
chauffer pour faire encore une fois des
économies les écoles il y a plus de
chauffage dans l'école c'est pour ça
qu'il y a plus d'école c'est qu'il y a
plus de quoi se chauffer et vous
soulignez malgré tout le panache je ne
sais pas mais en tous les cas c'est
visage qui reste malgré tout souriants
mais oui mais l'Arménie l'histoire de
l'Arménie c'est une succession de
malheur d'invasion de destruction et à
chaque fois chaque fois il se remonté si
le terme résilience est utilisé par
Boris à propos des Juifs à présent
mondiale les Arméniens incarnent aussi
cette résilience c'est jamais jamais
baisser les bras toujours se relever
toujours garder la dignité ça leur a
coûté cher d'ailleurs parce que ils ne
sont pas spectaculaires les Arméniens
lorsqu'il souffrent ils ne sont pas
enfermés dans des camps et à supplier
aujourd'hui les magasins sont vides
c'est pas la carte mais vous avez pas
des queues devant les magasins pour
qu'ils feraient des belles images pour
la télé et c'est peut-être ça aussi qui
manque pour eux c'est de pour intéresser
le monde il faut des images et pour des
images et bah il faut jouer ce jeu là et
ne le veulent pas ils ne le voudront
jamais parce qu'il resteront toujours
droit et digne dans leur souffrance on
va regarder justement une deuxième image
pour commenter cette actualité plus
précisément une vidéo la voici je vous
laisse Jean-Christophe la commenter ça
se passe en Australie
c'est l'Open d'Australie c'est Karen
frachonov qui est un joueur de tennis
russe mais qui évidemment n'a pas de
nationalité puisque les Russes sont
bannis des compétitions sportives depuis
un an mais qui est d'origine arménienne
de deux côtés d'ailleurs de côté de
grand-père et de sa mère je crois et qui
lorsque je crois que c'est lorsqu'il a
gagné le 8e de finale ensuite il se
qualifie encore jusqu'à demi-finale a
écrit sur le sur la caméra
son soutien à l'arsa au 120 000
Arméniens d'arsa sa qualification pour
les cartes de finale
rester ferme resté fort larza et ça ça a
suscité la colère incommensurable de bas
coût de la Fédération de tennis
d'Azerbaïdjan très très efficace comme
je sais pas si vous pouvez me citer un
joueur de tennis azerbaïdjanais mais
compliqué là pourtant je suis fan de
mécanisme mais compliqué en tout cas en
tout cas les ingrédients demandent
quasiment l'exclusion de ce joueur parce
que il s'est permis d'avoir un discours
politique alors que c'est un discours
encore une fois là on est dans
l'humanité il y a 120 000 personnes qui
sont en train mourir un jour de tennis
qui n'est même pas arménien mais même si
il est d'origine d'arménienne qui dit
tenait bon c'est-à-dire résister survivé
et il est menacé ce qui montre bien que
l'Azerbaïdjan est en permanence en train
d'essayer de menacer de de d'effacer des
symbole qui rentre dans la minorité de
terreur surtout de terrain c'est la
politique depuis deux ans de
l'Azerbaïdjan avec les Arméniens c'est
les terrorisés pas forcément
physiquement même psychologiquement pour
les inciter à partir à quitter ce
territoire pour qu'il puisse l'occuper
c'est vraiment la politique et
aujourd'hui c'est la pire des politiques
de terreur c'est de affamer une
population et la réduire à mourir de
froid troisième image Jean-Christophe on
va la voir c'est la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale française
qui était en déplacement en Arménie il y
a quelques jours oui oui il y a beaucoup
de personnalités politiques françaises
qui qui sont allés en Arménie voire même
en arts aussi bien de gauche comme un
Hidalgo que de droite comme
François-Xavier ou Valérie intéresse ou
Éric Zemmour il y a quand même une
espèce de consensus au sein de toute la
classe politique française pour dire il
faut il faut aider les Arméniens et des
élus politiques qui l'ont fait ce qui
est important c'est que à la fois Gérard
Larcher président le lien président de
l'Assemblée nationale ils sont allés
sont les numéros 3 et 4 de l'État
français c'est pour ça que ce sont quand
même des signaux très forts sont il y a
des députés des sénateurs des
parlementaires mais maintenant il y a
aussi les présidents des deux assemblées
en France qui sont allés apporter leur
soutien au gouvernement de Nicole
pachinian qu'on voit sur la photo ce qui
laisse penser que après être numéro 3
numéro 4 on peut espérer numéro 2 voire
numéro 1 donc Emmanuel Macron Emmanuel
Macron peut-être en tout cas après votre
votre rencontre de lundi deux dernières
questions très rapidement
Jean-Christophe lundi les ministres de
l'Union européenne les ministres
européens se sont mis d'accord pour
établir une mission civile afin d'aider
à surveiller la frontière entre
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan cela était
demandé par l'Arménie ils ont été
entendus semble-t-il sur ce sujet ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
l'Arménie est enfin entendu écoutée
alors en fait il y avait lors du sommet
de Prague en octobre dernier Emmanuel
Macron a organisé en marge de ce sommet
au savier tous les épis Européens et des
pays appelés peut-être à entrer dans
l'Union européenne donc
en marge de ce congrès de cette
convention Emmanuel Macron a réussi à
organiser un mini colloque quadripartite
avec Charles Michel le président azéri
il a maniev et le Premier ministre
arménien Nicole pachignan il est resté
pendant des heures pour discuter et à la
sortie de ses réunions il a réussi à
imposé à ses collègues européens qu'il
voulait pas en entendre parler l'idée
d'une mission civile européenne qui
viendrait en Arménie le long de la
frontière pour étudier justement
observer la situation relever s'il y a
des cessez le feu qui sont violets ou
qui parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a quand
même les ingrédients qui occupent 150
km² de territoire Arméniens d'Arménie
illégalement et cette mission avait
devait rester un mois et en fait là ce
qui a réussi Emmanuel Macron c'est imp
la mission proposée et donc imposée
l'Union européenne de prolonger cette
mission parce que cette mission elle
sécurise quand même parce que quand
l'Azerbaïdjan veut attaquer l'Arménie
tirer sur des soldats Arméniens c'est
une chose tirée sur des civils irlandais
espagnol polonais c'est pas tout à fait
la même histoire
ça peut être efficace ça peut oui c'est
une forme de sécurité aujourd'hui je
crois qu'ils sont une vingtaine une
trentaine ils peuvent être 52 mains sans
et puis peut-être qu'un jour cette
mission peut être de devenir militaire
qui sait en tout cas c'est un geste fort
qui dit nous on est l'union européenne
on vous surveille merci beaucoup
Jean-Christophe merci on revient bien
sûr sur ce sujet dans de nombreux
papiers sur le Figaro et puis je
m'enchaîne également à retrouver notre
émission spéciale du club international
sur l'armén